we've got ted out live tonight ted
whenever you throw the baseball cap on
you look about 22 years old here's ted
take it away pal
hey brian uh good evening to you hard to
hear you because there's so much going
on down here and we timed it just right
just minutes ago they actually rang the
bell when father hidalgo symbolizing
father hidalgo making the battle cry
asking for independence from spain this
was back in 1810 they just rang the bell
a gentleman from the mexican consulate
is here and rang that bell uh not only
that but we also want to bring in a a so
a familiar face come on in guys come on
dave we want to bring in a familiar face
his name is alejandro milan okay and he
was the voice saying two songs in the
movie coco the disney film alejandro
malone's here this is his cousin chris
he's going to translate for us how
excited were you when you when they told
you to come down here to come sing the
the national anthem
yeah
i was so excited to to cancel the
national anthem of the united states
right here in this celebration so it's
so exciting that's great i gotta ask you
chris
how does a kid from henderson land a job
as the voice singing the voice for that
disney movie coco oh it's just skills he
has all the skills he has he has the
voice so my bro he did a good job on it
too so it's been so excited to hear
about when you got that job too right
yeah yeah i was so excited so
so i can uh participate in this movie so
excited and so
thankful for for everything okay i gotta
tell you before we sign off here you got
golden pipes we call them golden pipes
could you sing us a song from that movie
can you sing a song
elsa
[Music]
okay okay
i got goosebumps i got goosebumps and
there's a lot of a lot of women there
that just fainted right now just so you
know all right
i bet you denise's studio fainted thank
you so much elena appreciate it all
right guys golden pipes great job